i don't know if you know this but warren
buffett made like 97 of his wealth after
the age of 55.
um
so so it all happens very slowly he
started in his 20s or whatever and he
wasn't really well known until the 90s
and the same thing happened with us
where we didn't really talk about what
we did people would meet us and they'd
be like oh you're some schmoes from
victoria who owns some digital agency
you seem to own all these really boring
businesses you know whatever and so it
requires being kind of underestimated
and dismissed and playing a very boring
game while watching everyone else go and
make you know tens of millions billions
of dollars taking risk in startups
meanwhile we're just going how do we
take you know a hundred grand and make
10 15 20k a year on that money and just
keep compounding and so basically the
mental model was take 70 of our profits
and constantly reinvest take the other
30 live a nice life and that number went
down over time and yeah you do that for
17 years and it turns into a you know a
big number
[Music]
and something that you wanted to talk
about today was whether it's better to
own 100 of something and bootstrap it or
to give up equity for to partners
whether that's for sweat equity or money
or money but you uh we were talking
about that and i asked my audience
companies that were bootstrapped and
quite big and there's a few that are
doing billions a year in revenue and i
noticed two commonalities one a lot of
the things that were bootstrapped to be
really big they were things that were
easy to take bake loans against so it's
a lot of restaurant stuff so maybe they
took like loans against some equipment
or they took loans against
a building they owned things like that
the second thing was
i've noticed that there's a lot of
agencies that were bootstrapped and
became pretty substantial size agencies
or agencies or service-based businesses
so like recruiting uh companies um um
it services things like that where it's
basically you bill out people's time for
100 and you charge 300 or something like
that
well think about it you don't need
especially if you're a young person
and you can cut you got enough money to
live for a year you can go and start an
agency because at the end of the day
it's you go and sell you win a contract
as soon as you win the contract you go
and find a developer or you do the work
yourself and then before you know it
you're cash flowing and you're always
able to hire people
just in time for the work and so at the
end of the day there's really no burn
and it's very capital efficient and you
don't need
uh you don't even need an office anymore
i mean we we almost never had an office
and oh you know over time we had you
know a couple small ones or whatever but
the big [__] up a lot of these big
agencies make is they start starting
like these fancy humongous five million
dollar offices in new york and san
francisco and spain and you know
whatever um they're they're great
businesses if you run them right and how
many people work at meta lab now
i think it's about 170. how often do you
say to yourself i'm not sure if the the
headache is
the headache of having 170 employees is
always worth it
well it's very abstracted for me right i
haven't been in the business for
five or six years and the way we run
tiny now is that we meet with the ceo
once a year and otherwise they check in
whenever they need help with anything
and so when i was running it like first
it's exhilarating running an agency is
awesome when you're starting out you get
a seat at the table and all these places
you don't deserve to be right i was like
a 22 year old pip squeak and i was
meeting the founders of pinterest and
slack and you know all these amazing
places and they were asking me for my
opinion right it was it was crazy but at
a certain point you get so exhausted
you're making a good amount of money you
don't want to get on a plane to san
francisco every second day to go and
sell
and at that point you know it starts to
become a much more intensive business
and for me personally i don't enjoy
running businesses after about 15 or 20
people and so once i hit that point i
knew i needed to transition to a ceo
so when we were in the document you say
the pros and cons of bootstrapping and
owning 100
what do you have under those
well
i mean i think that i've changed my
opinion a lot on this like when i first
started i was like a jason freed david
hannemeyer hanson acolyte like 100
every business should be bootstrapped i
now think that's crazy and stupid and i
think there's certain businesses where
it's insane not to raise money right
like if you have an opportunity to grow
your business it's like the analogy i
always use is if you own a bakery and
there's a line out the door and you have
a single oven and you need to buy three
more ovens but you don't have the money
and in order to service the people in
the line you need to buy two more ovens
it's crazy not to raise money or go get
debt or something i just was never in
that position
and i think you know owning a hundred
percent or owning majority in your
business it's like a dictatorship and
dictatorships can be very good uh like
lee kuan yew from singapore or they can
go terribly like kim jong-un right and
the question is what's your personality
and what's going to work for you i mean
you can move insanely fast there's no
board there's no committee you don't owe
anyone anything you don't have an
outcome you know you don't have to ipo
you don't have to sell and you have
total integrity like when chris and i
buy a business we can look people in the
eye and be like we're cutting a check
like this is us right that's very
different
on the cons i mean you're on an island
you don't have anyone to really who's
aligned and cares and can tell you
you're being an idiot and so you can
really drive your business off the rails
and then you also think in a limited way
i mean i know so many entrepreneurs who
could 10x their business but they're so
addicted to their dividends or they're
conservative and so they don't so what
about this transformation
[Music]
i raised money for our podcasting
software company supercast i'm going to
raise money for our news business like
there are situations where it's logical
[Music]
all right and then i forgot to tell you
this but this is the most important
thing
i can't believe we didn't talk about
this earlier to be honest with you
because if you're listening to this and
you like what you're hearing right now
and you haven't gone and subscribed to
the my first million podcast wherever
you get your podcast
then that's the thing you've got to do
there's nothing more important than
doing that right now and don't do it
because i said to do it
do it because you want to do it do it
because that's who you are
what about that conversation of
employees employees saying they want
equity
and you don't get well it's just there's
certain businesses there's certain
businesses where we do and there's
certain ones where we don't right and
the big question is
what i always say to a
to an employee is
equal risk equal reward
and if the business is going to sell at
some point or we think it can ipo great
we'll love to talk about equity but
there's a cost to it right if you want
to make 300 grand a year and you don't
want to give up any of that 300 grand in
order to get stock options or buy equity
then it doesn't matter so i love i love
giving people the option and saying look
you can either give up some of your comp
or upside or whatever and we'll give you
stock options
or you can get the big salary and
prioritize cash and a lot of people
prioritize comfort and cash i find at
least you know outside of the bay area
by the way andrew you mentioned the guy
from singapore sam do you know this guy
leak on you
uh i know a little bit about him i
didn't realize he was a dictator i
thought they called him like the ceo or
something
no he's literally a dictator so like a
good the good dictator andrew can you
give us like the two minutes uh
two-minute kind of summary of who this
guy is and why he's awesome
so effectively he took over um singapore
is like an island tropical island state
um in asia and at the time it was like
rice paddies poverty like a bog
and he literally took it over you know
had an autocracy had total control and
he basically thought like a business
person and was like okay how do we make
this the most business friendly place
how do we optimize taxes how do we
ensure we have hyper competent
government how do we pay government
really really well uh how do we
incentivize the whole world to
manufacture and export
you know their products from here
and basically built it into
asia's kind of outside of hong kong i
think it's like the central banking and
finance uh hub in asia so it's a pretty
incredible story
and i think he his background is like
he's like a math and computer science
guy right like
he he doesn't come from
kind of this like you know uh political
background like he came from a different
sort of background and i think that's
why you got different ideas from from a
leader in charge
totally
you want to tell me you also had
something
i was going to say you had one thing you
tweeted out uh that's related to how you
run the business at tiny which is this
this higher one higher 10
uh framework what what is that because
that sounded interesting to me and i
think that that's like uh
from what i understood it was a pretty
useful concept so explain that
yeah so our ceos get super annoyed
because i say this all the time it's
probably the number one thing i say uh
and it's probably the biggest hack that
enabled us to build tiny over the last
eight years um
so i mean think about it like this so if
you had an army general who is
commanding a thousand troops but he's
still telling individual soldiers what
to do and he's personally restocking
their ammunition and he's shuffling
people around you'd be like what the
hell is this guy doing right but i think
a lot of people operate their business
like this i mean i certainly did in the
early days i would swoop and poop and
you know instead of hiring a vp
marketing i would go and i'd hire a
whole bunch of marketing people and just
kind of become the vp of marketing and
or i'd bypass people and tell people
what to do and what i realized is you
should never ever
hire the 10 people you should always
focus on hiring the one person so that
could be a ceo who will then go out and
hire all the executives or could be
hiring an executive who will hire an
entire team but uh it's just it's such a
hack right it's like 80 20. how do i do
20 of the work for 80 of the result um
and uh yeah i mean it took me ages to
figure this out i feel like i've only
cracked this in the last like five years
and i still chris will still catch me in
this he'll be like higher you know
higher one to higher 10.
but when you hire that mistake all the
time and when you hire that one person
how much
so let's say your business is doing
uh let's say 1 million in revenue it's
small no let's say a little let's say 10
million in revenue 2 million in in like
actual cash flow you have you hire that
one person you pay him
a lot of money 250 000 do you only hire
that 250 000 person when you know for a
fact you've got budget for like two more
people
yeah that i mean that's my approach
that's why i've shifted to is like i
hire
you know here's an example is like we
hired the ceo of aeropress
and
he asked me questions oh you know what
do you think about this higher that
higher and i just said that's your you
know that's your hire you know i hired
you i trust you 100 you make those hires
right and so it's complete delegation of
you know when i buy a business i make
two decisions who runs it and how are
they incentivized and unless they do
something dirty or horrible or the
business goes to [__] you know i just
leave them to it what's the trick on the
uh how are they incentivized so so
what's the
how do you think about that when you buy
a business and you say all right the
business today is here
and i think naturally it's gonna get to
there and i'm bringing on this person to
get it to be some inflection above that
and i also know that things can go wrong
so how do you think about that incentive
structure is it is it case by case
you're coming up with very unique
patterns or very unique uh you know
packages or do you have kind of one base
that you that you go off of
it's so different i mean like everyone's
incentivized differently there's there's
certain people where for example they
need to be able to say they're a partner
and they have equity there's other
people who don't care about that and
they want just targets to hit
i mean we've done everything from saying
okay let's say the business makes a
hundred million dollars and it's growing
at 15 percent you anything you do over
15 percent growth you get five percent
of right that's in its simplest we've
also done things where it's like you
know hey when the stock price hits x you
get a payment and i remember um i got to
have dinner with charlie munger like two
years ago and i was like what's the
perfect you know incentive structure and
he just said i've done hundreds and
everyone is different and i still don't
know what works i think it's really an
art not a science because
you know different people are just so
differently motivated and you actually
like steak so you
sorry one more sam when it's usually
usually when it's like ah it depends
there's there's that what that usually
means is the winning formula is
different a lot but there's usually a
common losing formula so what is the
common losing formula for incentives
the common losing formula is
them not being aligned on risk so for
example if they're able to use my money
and i can keep injecting money into the
business but it in no way hurts them so
for example they don't get diluted or
they don't have to pay a high interest
rate or you know
if it goes bankrupt they don't lose
anything that's a huge problem and i've
learned that over the last five years
and so now what i try and do
is if somebody wants
equity i always make them write a check
right or or i loan them money and it's
literally a personal loan guaranteed by
their house or something right and it's
got it doesn't i don't want it to be so
much money it's going to ruin them or be
a problem but i i if someone wants
equity i'm like okay you got to put up
something because if the business fails
or goes down you gotta have a sense of
loss people feel a lot that people feel
lost more than they feel gain i just
imagine the wilkinson moving truck
coming in from the house they're like no
honey it's all gone wrong you have to
come when you put your own furniture
your own art on the walls they get to
live there but they have to know that
it's your house now and they truly we
have [__] we have done it we i
obviously you know i never want to do
that and it's always structured in a way
where it's not you know we're not going
to have to take their car or something
but i just want i want a feeling of like
there's got to be some downside you know
sam is going to take this like way too
far he's going to take their car and
it's like a punch plus like i get to
punch you
just because if you lose my money i'm
going to punch you
[Laughter]
yeah i love this game
you uh you also
speaking of that of risk you also hire
people really early you told me um i
don't know if you talked about those but
you were tinkering around with this bake
do you want to talk about the bait can
you mention the bakery or no
yeah well the bakery is kind of sad no
sorry not the bakery
the
ghost kitchen
ghost kitchen you tinkered with this
thing where you hired a baker and you
were making stuff to sell on doordash
and ubereats
and i don't know if it was entirely
illegal so we don't think about it but
the point i'm bringing up is that well
no i can i can i can tell well tell the
story then let me ask my question
sure so basically you know i'm pretty
interested in health and stuff and i was
trying to get off sugar and so i went to
a baker friend and i was like look can
you try and make like like sugar-free
cookies using modern you know there's
always like crazy modern sugars like you
guys have heard of magic spoon yeah yeah
like magic spoon uses uh allulose and
stevia and monk fruit and stuff so he
started making these and i was like okay
these are like not as good as a
chocolate chip cookie but they're like
90 percent there and i bet you a lot of
people would be into this as like a
replacement like think about halo top it
doesn't taste as good as ice cream you
can eat a [__] load of it and it's not
bad for you in the same way so i
basically made that we started making
all these treats we were cooking it out
of our office which is not technically
legal um and what happened was um i got
a call from island health which is like
the local health authority and they just
said hey you're using an ingredient
that's not approved in canada and
unfortunately allulose has not approved
in canada and so you just legally can't
serve food with it even though it's
generally regarded as safe and
everything um so i'm still gonna do it
at some point i think but i just legally
can't it sucks and i've never it's
insane to me you can hit up against
these regulatory issues like imagine
being a real estate developer and like
you have this amazing vision and then
city council is just like nope yeah like
that is insane to me as an internet
entrepreneur and that's what i was gonna
ask so you like hired a baker to do it
but then also with your uh newsletter
business your local news business you hi
i forget the guy's name but he's i've
talked to him a bit he's a nice guy
you've hired him to be the ceo and so
you you hire people pretty
yes and you you hire people pretty early
on and hiring someone to do something to
me is a huge risk because in my head i'm
like man if this guy's got a kid like
i'm like his kids now kind of my kid too
um you know like it's like a big risk if
he's quitting it that's how i felt when
my when my one of my first employees got
married i was like oh i've got a family
now um because i was like some of the
decisions i make are going to impact
this entire family and that's really
stressful and it's also a huge
conversation to convince someone who's
in their 30s 40s or whatever and they're
even in their late 20s to leave their
fancy gig at salesforce to bail and come
to my company that i'm going to pay them
45 000 that's a huge thing i i go when i
go to bed at night that stresses me out
but you seem like you overcome that
pretty easily you hire people relatively
early and you're like yeah it's no big
deal i'm just going to hire this person
what's that like like what are you
thinking when you do that
[Music]
all right what's going on just a quick
break a quick interruption scroll down
into the description box on youtube and
you're gonna see a link to the hustle
the hustle is a daily email it gives you
all you need to know about business and
tech news i started it years ago um and
it's awesome it's kind of how this
podcast got started so check it out the
hustle
scroll down do it
well i've lost i've i've messed that up
a lot and i think you guys know my whole
story about losing 10 million dollars
building project management software
like that was a perfect example where i
got ahead of myself the business didn't
make sense and i threw a bunch of
spaghetti at the wall and none of it
stuck and i had to let a whole bunch of
people go and it was really horrible and
sad and you know it was like a 10-year
slow death right so i've been through
that so now it's more
with the amount of scar tissue i have
i've enough i have enough signal where i
can be like okay i'm going to try this
and with the bakery i was just
contracting a friend right that was the
best example i said this is an
experiment with the news business i
actually ran it for three years before i
partnered with farhan and he took over
as ceo and by that point there was
enough signal it was slapping me in the
face i was like this is a big
opportunity
and is that the case with all with all
the things that you start
we take that yeah usually like if i if i
go and i i hire a ceo i'm pretty high
conviction that there's something there
or there's already a business that
supports has cash flow what i would
never do is be like hey there's uh you
know i have an idea for this i'll just
go hire a ceo like i i would never do
that
andrew i feel like you've reached this
point and
i used to be like how did these
[__] do this where i remember i
was doing a startup
it was so hard to get my one thing to
work and then i would meet people who
were like
oh yeah so i have that past success then
i have my current success and then
here's my three side successes that i
had this idea and then we just started
doing it and then guess what the lines
out the door and then this other one
it's like kind of cool we just started
it you know like i accidentally you know
my hand just fell on my keyboard and i
accidentally wrote this app it was
amazing it went viral and this other
thing that i just tweeted about and then
this all coming together nicely and i
just remember being like what
do they know something i don't know is
there just like extreme luck component
and i felt that way for many years five
six years straight when i was pushing
the boulder up the hill with my startup
and then i now have experienced exactly
what the thing that i was most jealous
of and i have no idea what switched in
between where like the last five things
i've tried have all worked and all
worked pretty much immediately and it
doesn't matter how big or small like you
know whether it's like the podcast or
the course or uh you know
my e-commerce business or my the new
milk road newsletter business like
each of these has just worked straight
away in a bigger way than anything i'd
ever done before
um
with less work and less stress than like
the old stuff i used to do and i have no
idea what changed or i have a kind of an
inkling but i don't really know sam have
you ever thought about this or you know
what i'm talking about what do you think
i know i know exactly what you're
talking about and i completely agree
you're on a roll right now um and what's
your inkling i i have a feeling
my my my answer is it's kind of like a
shitty it's like a mindset like
abundance attitude and being on being on
offense versus defense but what's your
what's your
what's your inkling
so my inkling is that
i
switched up my situation so like i was
in one situation for a very long time
like it was a nice situation very nice
situation but it was like where i was
going to this office every day working
with these people in this hierarchy with
this boundary box of like what project
or projects we can work on and like what
success might look like and as soon as i
got out of that i was just me i was like
oh okay so now that it's just me that i
have to look out for
i guess i could just do a podcast i
didn't have to have like this big
venture billion dollar outcome i didn't
have 20 engineers to go tell what to do
i had no engineers so i just did what i
could do with no engineers which was
like i'll do a podcast i'll do a course
i'll do i'll just try to get big on
twitter let's see what happens and oh
you know like five tweets go viral and
boom got 200 000 followers it's like
there's these things that i just wasn't
doing before because i think before i
had a really set thing of like here's
what i need to do like here's the only
way to win
and i had like almost too much ammo i
had like too many people
at my disposal too much funding too much
everything
and because of that i had a very narrow
window of what could work and so i was
just trying to come up with ideas that
might work versus
oh let me just try this because i'm i
just kind of want to try it
and then when once i got into i just
kind of want to try it and i didn't have
it i didn't have to worry about what
other people thought or i didn't have to
come in and manage anybody in that day
and tell them what to do i didn't have
like investors to go pitch to i just did
the thing and then all of a sudden i
feel like you know sort of like
all the talents and skills that i had
been building up over the past 10 years
like finally got to just do them
yeah don't you think it's like dating or
something though where it's like you
know you date a couple crazy girls and
it's really exhilarating and then over
time you're like wow that was horrible
and there's pattern matching you're like
okay when i go to a restaurant and a
girl is rude to the waiter that's a no
right and in the same way with business
you go oh okay like i used to think i
wanted to build all these kinds of
businesses but those were 10 foot
hurdles i don't want to jump 10 foot
hurdles i want to jump one foot hurdles
and so if you think about it all the
stuff you're doing they're in your you
know circle of competence and they're
relatively simple to execute they don't
require a lot of people they don't
require funding i think learning that is
like a 15-year overnight success kind of
thing where it just clicks suddenly
right and i'll catch myself occasionally
getting pulled down rabbit trails of
like oh what if i did this crazy you
know drone ai startup whatever but then
i always go back to base hits and i and
i think
there's this third component
well go ahead you go ahead
all right
oh my god what's going on
all right i'm gonna go there's this
third component of of confidence and so
i think that because of like my work
i've been more confident and i
understand like well if i invest a
dollar here i think i can make at least
uh three dollars the next two years so
like just understanding how machines
like money making machines work
investments but then also i think sean
because we get to hang out with we hang
out with each other we hang out with
andrew we hang out with our circle of
friends we hang out with all the people
we've had speak at our events we hang
out with our um podcast guests it
becomes more normal like succeeding has
become far more normal than not
succeeding actually and not succeeding
is just like oh yeah it's going to
happen but then you just move on you do
the next thing and it's like and then
inevitably it works so it's not if it's
not when it's if and i think that
confidence has actually helped a ton
where so for example now if someone
wants to like real estate's an an easy
one because it's so predictable but with
real estate you're like oh man putting a
hundred thousand dollars down on this
house is a lot of money that's a you
know that's six figures it's like well
dude but it's going to make 12 it's like
well i don't know that and i'm like yeah
i know but it's going to do that so you
actually want to invest more so like
that confidence of just knowing the
emotions and knowing the routine and
process has actually helped a lot
totally yeah the other thing i was gonna
say is uh which is what you guys both
just said but framed differently is i
was taking a shitload of market risk
before
and now i basically take almost no
market risk i just take execution risk
and before
even if i felt like i executed great
which i did i feel like i did and a
couple of the projects that we had done
and during my like kind of like the
the previous startup um the market risk
was too high like there was just no it
was like inventing a new
[__] like a new science you know on a
new land and it was just the market risk
was way too high now i'm just doing
things that are like oh i knew i just
know that this works and i just need to
do it well so it's like ecommerce is
nothing there's no
fancy science to it um and i had buddies
who did it and i just used their model
and i just did my own in my own lane of
their model
milk road is the hustle but in the
crypto lane which is the crypt the lane
i like right it's like i just took your
blueprint for the hustle and i just copy
pasted over here
from there i know dude i saw that you
literally copy and pasted the twitter
handle it was hilarious your twitter
description is literally copy
i sent you some old resources from the
hustle and we call themselves this your
smart good-looking friend or something
who tells you everything you need to
know about
you just copy that and you put in a
business attack you just put like delete
crypto or something like that
and actually the thing is it wasn't even
you know why it did that uh i remember
seven years ago or eight years ago when
you first said that to me and the very
first like
you know like you kind of sat me down
you're like look people are not people
our age like we don't watch msnbc and
like cnn and this stuff for our our
information that's not the brand we
trust
and you you said it you're like i just
want to be like they're smart and i
remember you said it i shouldn't be like
you're smart no [__] friend who just
explained tells you what's going on and
i was like i like it clicked with me
eight years ago and so when it came time
to do this i was like that's the exact
description the smart no [__] friend
i think one more thing andrew is that
i look at
i i used to you kind of said that
andrew and in terms of like financial
success which is a big but not only uh
measure of success andrew you're like
a grand slam at the moment you know
you're you're
i imagine you're incredibly wealthy and
you've built businesses that are
incredibly large so by that
measure of success you are like way out
there and for a while i think i like
admit you're like mystical to me where
i'm like how is he doing this
now it's changed to where i think i
acknowledge that you definitely have
talent that makes you special you for
sure have skills that make you special
but really
a lot of it is also i don't know what
percentage of it is each but let's just
say a third a third a third a third of
it is
well he's just been doing it for like
15 years now or a certain amount of time
and he just like took the risk of
raising or building the business and
then he raised the money a little bit
for the fun and so it's not a matter of
like how is he doing is doing this it's
just like well if i want that life like
i probably could do it i just have to
dedicate 15 or 20 years and go through
the same motions that he does and that
may or may not fit the
what i like
the interesting thing is i don't know if
you know this but warren buffett made
like 97 of his wealth after the age of
55 um is so so it all happens very
slowly he started in his 20s or whatever
and he wasn't really well known until
the 90s and the same thing happened with
us where we didn't really talk about
what we did people would meet us and
they'd be like oh you're some schmoes
from victoria who owns some digital
agency you seem to own all these really
boring businesses you know whatever and
so it requires being kind of
underestimated and dismissed and playing
a very boring game while watching
everyone else go and make you know tens
of millions billions of dollars taking
risk in startups meanwhile we're just
going how do we take you know a hundred
grand and make 10 15 20k a year on that
money and just keep compounding and so
basically the mental model was take 70
of our profits and constantly reinvest
take the other 30 percent live a nice
life and that number went down over time
and uh yeah you do that for 17 years and
it turns into a you know a big number um
ironically i still feel just as at risk
and terrified as i did 15 years ago
that's real and i think it's the classic
thing of you you're not you're not
actually scared i'm scared are you
because i have liquidity now and i'm i'm
scared but i'm like am i as scared as
when i only had twenty thousand dollars
in my bank account i can't just say oh
no no but it's it's maybe it's different
for me because you know i have
a an un
for if you told me 10 years ago how much
you know cash we have or what our cash
flow is it would blow my mind and i'd
say how could you ever feel at risk the
problem is that the stakes are bigger
you know we have almost a thousand
employees now right so
there's a lot more
um you know there's the stuff that can
go wrong do i feel that i've built out a
castle with a whole bunch of moats and
stuff yeah absolutely and i'm better
diversified than i was 10 years ago but
there's still that kind of dust bowl
farmer mentality right it's actually
something i want to talk about um
like just
we all kind of have this feeling of like
the way i'd put it is i started chopping
wood just because i was anxious right
like 15 years ago in my backyard and my
neighbor pokes his head over the fence
and he's like hey can you chop some wood
for me for my fire i'll give you 20
bucks and i'm like okay amazing i didn't
know this was a business and then before
i know it
i've hired three or four buddies we're
all chopping wood in the backyard we're
a merry band we're selling to the whole
neighborhood it's awesome i love it and
then one day 15 years later i wake up
and i'm in a sawmill and i own 15
sawmills and all i do all day is file
papers but there's still this part of me
that beats myself up for not chopping
wood right i still have this mindset
even though all the machines do all the
labor there's still this part of me
that's constantly saying you need to
chop wood you need to chop wood and so i
think
you're gonna you know you you guys have
this for sure like it doesn't matter how
much you have how diversified whatever
it is you have a need to do labor and
there's an anxiety that you're
harnessing to perform
that's a good ass analogy
i'm not gonna lie the first 30 seconds
while you're explaining it i thought you
legitimately took up wood chopping as a
hobby and i was like oh that's cool
it must be uh cathartic
and then i realized i was inside of a
charlie munger uh or warren buffet
analogy
like parable
um
you have this thing on here that's
that's pretty cool bad guys usually win
as a bad guy myself i would love to hear
yes uh
what you mean by this
oh man okay so do you think you're a bad
guy i've got a story
i don't think you're a bad guy
go ahead
i think a bad guy is a full-on con
artist who lies i call myself a bag
rather than calling myself a good guy
and having all the comments on youtube
tell me i'm a bad guy it's easier just
to call myself a bad guy and have people
tell me the opposite or bad meaning uh
not bad meaning bad but bad meaning good
that's how it is
so
i'm sure you guys have had this
experience and i'll kind of anonymize
this story in this case it's a bad girl
bad girls usually win but um so this
this happened to me like almost 10 years
ago i was really overwhelmed i was
running like five businesses i got
introduced to this older woman and she
had just sold her business for 20
million bucks super successful and she
kind of says hey i'll mentor you i'll
help you out and so she comes over to my
office we start white boarding and i'm
just like holy crap this person is a
genius she could help me so much and so
first she's an advisor and mentor and
then eventually she's like hey how about
i come in and i'll help you with
marketing and sales and so i inject her
into the business she starts killing it
like business takes off everything going
great um
but i did zero diligence right she
legitimized herself
by being this super successful person
and because she was so successful i was
just grateful to have her she was like a
miracle and made all these problems go
away for me and then suddenly the cracks
started appearing so
people started saying she was lying
she was spending money in weird ways
there you know her expenses were out of
control
you know staying in crazy hotels all
sorts of stuff and it turned out that
she was lying and like falsifying
documents she hadn't sold her business
she wasn't rich or successful and when i
called a bunch of people that she'd
worked with in the past like a bunch of
them had had terrible experiences right
so we fired her we move on
and i'm in this very odd spot where
ethically you know i want to be like
okay this is a bad person i want to
shoot up a flare and i want to be like
everybody watch out right and i'm
thinking like okay you know people will
diligence her they'll call me you know
she she won't be able to keep you know
pulling this off um but legally i don't
know what it's like in the us but in
canada when someone calls you for a
reference call you're quite limited you
can basically just say
you know i wouldn't work with them again
and do your diligence and so i usually
say
and i just want to like i'm not allowed
to talk about it
and they get the hint right that's smart
i i said a bunch of stuff like that like
you know i i would never work with this
person again it's one of the worst
professional experiences of my life
whatever but almost always those people
go on to work with them and you realize
these people are just incredibly
charming and they always assume you're
the bitter ex-girlfriend right because
they've obviously buttered you up and
told some story and so this woman you
know i see her on linkedin and she's
still succeeding and going every year
she's somewhere new and you know people
like this they don't get super rich
they're so short term and if they only
knew how much money you could make by
not being a crook they would probably be
ethical um but it just it was so sad to
me and i wanted my sense of justice was
like i gotta put a stop to this and you
just realize like no like you just have
to let go never wrestle a pig you'll
both get dirty but the pig will enjoy it
and so you know these people are out
there and they continue to succeed and
unless they're elizabeth holmes and they
get you know in the wall street journal
they're fine
i want to know who the person is
i will never say
[Laughter]
you had another example of a guy at a
famous company who
you know you had some fraud or you had
some issues with people not being honest
as well remember you told me that about
that one folk
i don't know i don't know which one that
is
i mean look at like you guys talked
about um
navi and jane uh on a podcast maybe like
10 episodes ago
and i mean like there's a perfect
example right there's this guy who
basically did a pump and dump that's my
understanding alleged alleged pump and
dump um but these people go on right
unless they're criminally indicted and
even you know people who are criminally
indicted look at michael milken michael
milken was literally uh front-running
his own investors committing tons of
like outright fraud that if you were his
investor you would hate went to jail for
10 years and now he's lauded as a
philanthropist i mean or how about him
always win i mean you know the guy do
you guys know uh
i think his name is gerbash he's
g is what people would call him he's a i
think he's indian an indian guy indian
american and he started a thing called
gravity something what was it called
gravity
gravity four and then he started another
one called like radium blue radium is
that what it was
and radium radium one and he got
arrested he was on oprah as this like
you know
uh 150 million dollar man under 30 or
something like that like the best
bachelor most available bachelor all
this stuff he's good looking guy he got
in trouble
three two or three different times both
times he basically locked his girlfriend
in
their apartment and it was there was a
camera there i don't know what he was
thinking and he was hitting her and just
being an i mean just a horrible guy got
arrested spent time in in in uh jail
months got out raised money again for
starting the same company now he's
overseas because he's kind of burned all
of his bridges here in in san francisco
in america he's overseas i think he
raised money again for another ad tech
company
this is the hard part is if someone is a
i mean typically someone who does bad
things like truly unethical things
they're either a psychopath or a
narcissist and they're very very
charming they're very compelling they're
fun to hang out with they're fascinating
they're great to listen to it's hard not
to like them i mean one one actually
heuristic after having that experience
is i actually had a company that i
looked at investing in and i liked the
ceo so much and he was so compelling
that i didn't invest because it made me
suspicious right or wrong i was just
like i left the meeting and i was like i
would buy anything from this guy and i
just want to give him all my money right
now and i stopped myself and i was like
this is that feeling don't invest right
i probably made a mistake but you know
maybe i'm too concerned but it's crazy
the same i'm the same way and i'm
willing to throw out the good with the
bad just to steer clear of the bed
because i know how intoxicating
that type of grifter is um and you know
i've actually put in some like you you
talk about air gapping for like you know
security purposes i've now done that on
on decision making for some investments
as well like so andrew you sent out an
email
to to uh to me say a couple others about
a business that you're raising money for
and it's a really great email like it's
a truly great email i gotta give you a
lot of credit and i actually wanted to
ask you
sam some help me with this i was gonna
ask you what goes into writing an email
like that
it wasn't like oh the writing wow this
this uh sentence structure was so
fantastic right obviously that helps but
it was the thinking it was the way of
framing the business and the
opportunities telling how you stumbled
into the opportunity what time you know
like your your analogy to you you can
bleep this if you want to chipotle like
you really did a good job of framing
this business
and it was so good in fact that i said i
am not going to reply to this for like
at least 48 hours because
if i read this email i'm going to say
give this person my money instantly like
rega it was almost like whatever out of
10 the business opportunity was it was a
10 out of 10
like pitch
and i actually
when i look back at businesses that i
invest in that that go on to do well
it's usually actually a nine out of ten
business opportunity um with a you know
sort of five out of ten pitch and in
fact it's only midway through the
conversation with this person that i'm
like oh wait so you basically have x and
they're like yeah i'm like well why
didn't you just say that and they're
like well no i did kind of right and i
was like oh dude you have no idea how to
pitch your own business
but that to me once that happens i know
wow i'm actually like
i underweighted the opportunity because
the pitch was so bad versus
overweighting a business opportunity
because the pitch is so good and that's
become like a standard practice yours
was just one example but that's become a
standard practice for me of like
beware of the 10 out of 10 pitch be
aware of the 1010 charm person that you
want to hire or that's gonna help you
with your business
the biggest one that i've seen is you
get this uber charming pitch and then
you say okay what could go wrong and
they say nothing right and you're just
like no this is insane this is
terrifying i've had like five or six
different pitches where that was the one
signal and it went to zero or bankrupt
or criminal how's the news business
going um
it's good it's really good actually we
just uh hit a profit in my hometown in
victoria our first market uh we're now
in eight different cities and i'm super
stoked about it as you can witness uh
based on that email that email how how
quickly because
you might have a knack for
just understanding and framing
businesses that's probably a superpower
of yours i think he has that how quickly
did that come together for you
uh how quickly did i write it um well i
mean it's something i've been thinking
about and kind of talking about a little
bit publicly for two or three years now
so i had all the analogies and stuff
formed um but i mean i wrote that in
like an hour or two and then sam just
helped me touch it up and then my
typical writing structure is i'll write
something in the first draft and then
i'll sit with it for two weeks or
something like that so i sat with it for
a week and then finally i sent it out um
but it's crazy like i don't know if you
guys get this something that drives me
insane is i get all these emails from
people who are raising money and it's
literally just a template like it almost
looks like they're sending it out with
salesforce or something the formatting
is wrong it's generic it's not properly
addressed to me and i always think like
what i was trying to do with that email
is i wanted the first sentence to hook
you and so i think the first sentence in
that email was in 2019 i was pissed off
right and then dave you know line one
you're like what's he pissed off about
what's going on right there's a bit of a
hook nobody knows how to use those
copywriting tools to pitch in written
form i think a lot of people are very
good at pitching um you know in a in an
actual pitch setting or whatever um but
yeah it's been it's been a great tool to
be able to do those tweet storms and
emails and stuff the most important
sentence of of anything you write it's
the it's the first sentence
well i love that one what's the line
that you said um
let me be very clear right you're just
like oh [__] like this person means
business what's going on here
[Laughter]
yeah sam is [__] good at this and in
fact i made the criminal mistake when i
asked you this question which is if you
go to michael jordan and you say mike
how do you jump so high
he'll if he's being nice he'll try to
answer something something but it's not
going to actually tell you in the same
thing how do you know steph steph curry
how do you shoot your jump shot to be
and how do you shoot better than anybody
else uh
people who are truly great at something
they have very low awareness to the
actual like how why and what
is making it so great
um and there there is a way to ask
questions about greatness but it's not
how do you do the thing you're great at
uh because people will sort of fumble
around and they'll try to tell you
something but it really has nothing to
do with with how they do the great thing
like for example
what you did great in that uh email was
first you decided to not make it a
template
that decision probably comes from you
some of you you're some way that you
view the world and like that you know
observation you had about pitches that
we're coming to that most people just
don't have the second thing was
when you framed the business you used
the analogy of like these local
franchises
that was because you had studied other
other great businesses just for fun you
probably studied the business of
chipotle and mcdonald's and other
businesses not that you were ever going
to start a restaurant but you stored
that somewhere in the recesses of your
mind and so when you saw something else
that was a local franchise you knew how
to like apply that and and so like you
know it's very hard to actually describe
what goes into
the art of making that happen right um
well not only that but being able to
communicate emote you know why does this
have a competitive advantage and in this
email i kind of go through the history
of the news business local news why
local news is so much more uh white has
a better moat right and you think about
it you go why would that be interesting
you know 50 000 people to 300 000 person
cities that seems like a small market
but in reality it's the stuff nobody
wants you're fishing where the fish are
off the beaten but
and you can dominate a local market
you've always done this so i actually
read your email um when i was when you
sent it to me in google drive and i was
like oh this is really good i'm gonna
because i was putting together this
course where i just like aggregate good
writing and i send it to people and i
was like i gotta i'm gonna use some more
of his stuff let's see what's out there
and i went and read all your stuff on
medium and i think there's like 10 or 12
things or something
and
you follow the same format over and over
again which you
it's it's you clearly are influenced by
warren buffett and uh you're influenced
by like traditional storytelling
techniques but if you go to your medium
you're actually
uh pitching your business on medium
constantly you're just not actually
there's just no call to action so you
don't actually care if it seals a deal
but there's like things where your cat
you have a headline called so
you didn't mean to do this but you could
have done this so it could have been
we're raising a million dollars for our
company but instead you made the
headline
we're um
uh you you the headline was joe rogan
could be the world's first podcasting
billionaire is that what it was that was
that it
no it was he got rid of joe rogan first
is joe rogan got ripped off which is
funny because he just signed 120 million
dollars yeah that's what it was
counter
so that was it was a good ass headline
and then you explain so that the emotion
there was shock which always does really
well so you're shocked like what the
hell you're saying that he got low ball
a hundred dollars is so much money and
you're like no you see it's nonsense you
see howard cern does this rokin could
have done this it just so happens that
we have a company that does that that's
how i know about it and then like if you
wanted a call to action so you have your
attention interest desire already there
if you want your action to make this a
full ada formula you could have been
like ps4 of course you can't do this
it's illegal but you go to the ps we're
raising money for our company and
see this is this is like you've you've
always said like the most valuable skill
is copyrighted i think both you guys
have said that like a hundred percent i
i chuck up the only reason meta lab
worked was because we would pick fights
we'd write these controversial articles
and we knew how to like we i i if
there's one thing i'm good at it's just
like taking um taking a boring topic and
just finding a wedge and getting people
going on it and that always results in
people knowing of you and passing your
name around and you become a topic of
conversation and it led in our case to
lots of client work and other stuff so i
if i think everyone needs to read the
book made to stick that was the book
that like really clicked for me i don't
know if you guys are very chip heath out
of stanford we talk about this
totally and it's that one that first
line the first line just has to hit you
the um the best thing you do so so i
think
uh if i was going to break it down the
middle of your writing is is like
inspired by or influenced by you know
some ways warren buffett but you're his
stuff is very dry right warren buffett
grew up without the clickbait generation
he doesn't need to to do that uh but
like 37 signals so like dhh or jason
freed like to me your writing is so
similar to theirs that i can tell you
know that was like a you know pretty
major influence on it and one thing that
they do amazingly well is they
they will
basically pick a fight while
simultaneously taking the moral high
ground and i think you do that amazingly
well too what i mean by that is
you'll say like you know joe rogan got
ripped off but you're not you're not
criticizing joe rogan you're actually
saying uh you know joe you you sold
yourself short and you know an artist
and a creator like you should not sell
yourself short for some to some company
who's gonna take advantage of you here
and so you're taking the moral high
ground
while picking you know going against the
grain and like sort of doing a call out
which is amazing most call outs just
basically it's somebody you know
slingshotting from the crowd and you
know they're sort of a sniper that's
like you know angry at them and so i've
never been able to do this but i've
noticed that you do this and thirty
seven students does this amazingly well
they say facebook is overvalued and
they'll talk about why facebook is
overvalued and then they'll talk about
you know like we're sorry we're just the
kind of guys that like businesses that
have actual revenues and profits but oh
you know call us crazy and so they're
taking the moral high ground and they're
saying that this facebook valued at the
time remember it was famously like why
billions of dollars i would i would
argue i would argue those guys would not
be where they are today without
copyright i doubt and i think that's
like the sawdust from their sawmill
right it's like hey we got [__] on the
app store what would most people do okay
we'll just go in with apple they used
that as the biggest marketing
opportunity ever they were on every talk
show they were their names were
everywhere i mean they also got kind of
canceled as well so there's a cost to
that but um they've done an amazing and
that's 100 where i learned it i worship
those guys for years i call it like the
malcolm gladwell effect so with malcolm
gladwell you um read his books and you
have to remember that a lot of what he's
saying is just theory there's no there's
some proof that it's real but it's not
proven
and um but he's such a good storyteller
that you think like oh what you're
saying is just a fact like
have you heard a story about david and
goliath it's wonderful and he likes it
he's like actually david goliath wasn't
that hard of a contest because it turns
out goliath was like mentally uh
challenged or like had some issues where
he like and he's also blind he couldn't
see he he like he had this thing where
he was so big that it ruined it it had
like giganticism or something like that
and so and then also like david was a
shepherd and they're actually so good at
throwing these rocks that they could
take a bird out of the sky so it's
really like just basically taking a a
big dumb blind giant and shooting him in
the head with a gun that's not hard and
like that's his argument about he's like
david goliath it's nonsense and
is he right i don't there's no proof who
knows is david goliath even real we
don't even know that but you like hear
this story and it changes you but the
problem that i have with base camp and
other good writers and this is something
that you have to be really careful of i
i work on all the time like i can be
such a good storyteller that i can get
you to think that something's real even
though like i'll tell you but there's no
proof but like i'm gonna write it in
such a way and base camp does this all
the time where they say well they'll
write something and i'm like oh this is
the truth this is how the world is like
well no let's let's not forget this is
an opinion
right
totally and there's lots of nuance and
going back to what we're talking about
with bootstrapping i i read all their
stuff i drank the kool-aid and i you
know i love those guys they built an
amazing business but you can't just have
that perspective it's very nuanced
there's there's you know like i said
there's so many situations where it is
logical to raise money and if you talk
to dhh 10 years ago he'd say salesforce
and facebook will be bankrupt in 10
years and this doesn't make sense and
again i love these guys and i know them
both they're awesome guys a huge fan
wouldn't have built my business without
them but um i do think they they present
everything in a very black and white way
which i think benefits them in a because
it makes them more compelling no one
wants to hear nuance
this has been a good pod what do you
think sean
yeah it was good there's i mean there's
a couple others we wanted to do but
we're way over so we should uh we should
wrap it and do another one soon
i know we didn't really yeah i think we
got like we have like we have like 20
topics to do so
it's like here's the five pillars of
happiness like do i want to be happy i
should probably ask about that one like
i would like to be happy
and then the jamie dyson thing there was
the whole you wanted to come on because
you're like i read this book about dyson
i want to come talk about it we didn't
even talk about it
oh man i'm so excited to talk about him
he's incredible all right well let's do
it let's do another one unless you have
time i don't know we could keep going if
you want but otherwise let's do another
one and uh we'll do dyson and smothers
yeah i gotta i gotta roll i got a lunch
in 12 minutes all right man good good
sweetie
okay see you guys that was fun
[Music]
you